[Music]
Hogwarts will always be there to welcome
you home but will it really what if
things aren't as they seem today we'll
take you on a journey and explore ten
really weird Harry Potter theories the
last one will really make you rethink
how you see the Wizarding World don't
forget to subscribe to the things and
give this video a thumbs up now let's
check out some weird Harry Potter
theories
Dumbledore's manipulative AF let's start
with an observation plenty of people
seem to have gotten when reading or
watching Harry Potter we learned a lot
of things about Dumbledore over the
years but many people have seen his
behavior in a different light for
example a redditor explained how
Dumbledore is actually a very flawed and
manipulative character for example
Dumbledore used Snape's love for Lily to
protect Harry everyone always talks
about Harry having Lily's eyes but
that's exactly how Dumbledore managed to
manipulate Snape into helping Harry but
it wasn't just Snape he also pretty much
manipulated Harry to get Slughorn back
at Hogwarts without even telling him
anything about the position he'll be
teaching at this redditor also states
that it was particularly Dumbledore
fault Sirius passed away if you think
about it Dumbledore a new Snape and
Harry didn't get along and that their
aquaman see lessons wouldn't be as
successful it was one of Dumbledore's
biggest mistakes and let's not forget
that he kept it Draco at Hogwarts even
though he knew exactly what Draco was up
to in the first place while it's clear
that Dumbledore did a lot of things out
of love theorists also note that he
might have had a difference more
manipulative agenda Horcruxes are even
more evil than you thought this theory
is pretty insane we all know the
Horcruxes are already evil but this
theory states that they're even more
crazy than we thought
did you notice that everytime Horcruxes
are mentioned someone talks about evil
magic even JK Rowling stated that the
process of making a Horcrux is too
horrible to actually go into detail
about and since we've seen pretty much
all the horrible things in the books
there's only a few left in order to
prepare the vessel from the Horcrux
people must die but we don't actually
know anything about the dark magic that
prepares said vessel and now
about the spell that must be performed
to move the fragments of the person's
soul into the vessel so how does it all
work really this theory states that the
process of making a Horcrux involves
cannibalism of course Harry's case was
an exception but considering just how
horrible this ritual is it's pretty
possible that the evil process of
creating a Horcrux involves some kind of
cannibalism it makes sense right
Arthur Weasley was cursed this is one of
these saddest theories ever this theory
comes from a blog called skulkin scum
and we really recommend you read the
entire thing but in short this harry
potter fan is convinced that Arthur is
actually under the Imperius curse at
some point during Voldemort's reign we
know that the Imperius curse was a real
issue back in the day and it costs a lot
of headaches for the ministry one of the
points of this theory is that the Death
Eaters actually targeted younger
ministry officials as a part of their
operation
Voldemort screw always took advantage of
younger and more vulnerable workers this
is particularly evident in Ludo
Backman's trial but in Goblet of Fire
crouched aka moody also tells Ron that
the Imperius curse gave the ministry a
lot of trouble at the time when Baal de
mort was on the rise Arthur would have
been a fairly young worker which means
he could definitely be the target of
Death Eaters curse this theory comes
with plenty of other points so we really
recommend you to have a read over ats
Calkins com hallucinations this is a
pretty popular theory but it really does
change the way we see the entire story
it states that Harry's simply imagined
and hallucinating the entire thing the
theory states that harry's an abused
child who's also pretty much emotionally
neglected we've seen how the Dursleys
treat him and how excited he was every
time he got a Christmas present and
remember the moment when Hagrid rescued
Harry from the Dursleys
psychologists taissa this is known as
fantasy coping victims of abuse are
known to create alternate realities in
order to cope with the abuse they're
facing but this theory gets even more
surreal it's states that the abuse can
also be seen in the so called Hogwarts
Hospital Harry's friends usually get
treated for far less serious things but
he seems to get broken arms cracked
skulls and he's constantly in for
life-threatening
situations so could it be that harry has
actually subconsciously created this
magical world but he's actually still
living in the cupboard under the stairs
it's a scary thought especially if you
think about how many times he ended up
in that hospital childhood definitely
ruins the other chosen one so we all
know Harry and Neville have a lot of
things in common but one thing that
always bugs fans is the unexplainable
reason why Neville's broomstick was
acting strange during his first flying
lesson
the explanation is pretty simple Neville
is clumsy and he kicked his feet off the
ground before Madame hooch blew the
whistle well at least in the books
because he kicks off after the whistle
blow in the movies because Neville
didn't know how to fly a broomstick just
yet and went out of control but this
theory states that is not just Neville's
clumsiness that made the broomstick go
crazy according to some fans it was
quirrell's fault we all have seen curl B
which Harry's broom during Quidditch but
we also know he's read the prophecy and
at that time it wasn't clear whether
Neville or Harry was the chosen one so
what if Quirrell was the one that
actually jinxed Neville's broomstick and
then used the exact same trick on Harry
if coral was really responsible for the
broomstick accident Neville was pretty
lucky that all he got was a broken wrist
imagine the story without level although
this theory was never confirmed it's
pretty believable a werewolf this theory
is all about Draco Malfoy the entire
theory can be found at Draco Malfoy is a
werewolf calm and we bet you've already
guessed what this theory is about by now
according to some fans Draco is actually
a werewolf there are plenty of
statements that support this theory
including the fact that in the actual
books we never see Draco's dark mark
that would indicate he's actually a part
of Voldemort's crew we also know that
Fenrir Greyback a bloodthirsty werewolf
was actually a family friend we also see
Draco looking sickly in Harry Potter and
the half-blood Prince according to this
theory is because spin rare actually bit
Draco as a punishment for Lucius Malfoy
repeated failures and of course then
there's the fact that Narcissa Malfoy a
devoted Voldemort supporter turned on
him at the
final moments the theorist states that
this made no sense unless someone she
loved was no longer welcome in the
pureblood order and her love for Draco
was stronger than her loyalty to
Voldemort's this theory would definitely
change a few things however it turned
out to be false when Pottermore finally
released more backstory about Draco and
how he indeed was a Death Eater and not
a werewolf immortal seriously this
theory is pretty impressive
remember the prophecy where Trelawny
states that neither harry nor
Voldemort's can live while the other
survives we all just assumed that harry
is just destined to be destroyed by
Voldemort
but I'm gore user HP Wombats interpreted
the prophecy in another way if either
Harry or Voldemort can't really survive
at the hands of the other that means
that the one to survive is actually
immortal as a result - so yes Harry
could be immortal but there's an even
darker part to this theory we always see
Harry's parents present in the final
series it's clearly seen that there is
an afterlife available for Harry where
he'd be reunited with his parents but if
this theory is true and if Harry is in
fact immortal it means that he actually
sacrificed his death for baltimore's
passing which also means that he will
never ever have the opportunity to see
his family or any loved ones that have
passed in afterlife and considering he
doesn't even have the Elder Wand since
he broke it he's pretty much stuck being
alive whether he likes it or not now
that's a theory that will really ruin
your childhood Harry and Ginny Harry and
Ginny were probably one of the most
unusual couples ever despite the fact
that Ginny had a crush on Harry long
before he noticed that she's anything
more than Ron's sister that's precisely
what this theory is about as much as
people seem to have loved Harry and
Ginny and they did turn out to be the
endgame some fans seemed to think that
Ginny administered a love potion to
Harry if you think about it Harry was
always indifferent to Ginny but
everything changed in the half-blood
prince part of the series we've seen
Romilda vane use a love potion before
Anne's Moreau Gaunt's also used this
technique to make Tom Riddle fall in
love with her so could it be that this
was the reason why Harry suddenly
started
taking interest in Jenny if you remember
JK Rowland described it as a roaring
creature inside of Harry but isn't it
strange how Harry never even noticed
Ginny in a romantic way before this
imagined if Ginny actually did use a
love potion to make Harry fall in love
with her this would have definitely
turned things around and we're really
not sure we'll ever be ready for this
theory to be true
Ron is Dumbledore one of the weirdest
but probably most common Harry Potter
theories out there is the one where Ron
is actually a time-traveling Dumbledore
this theory is old like 2004 old the
theory first came out from the Wizards
chess scene in the very first Harry
Potter series where Ron plays as a
knight and the king that's exactly what
Dumbledore is in the greater Wizarding
war to come according to the theory Ron
and Dumbledore share a lot of
similarities including one where
Dumbledore's Christmas wish
is a pair of warm socks and of course
let's not forget about the fact that
Dumbledore left Ron with a really
unexpected item after his passing this
theory is actually pretty long but if
you haven't yet experienced it it's a
must read for any Harry Potter fanatic
what do you think the Dumbledore really
beer on this theory was actually
debunked by JK Rowling herself but she
did admit that they open exhilarating
new vistas of possibility but that
possibility quickly closes when you've
realized that this would mean Dumbledore
actually liked Hermione nope nope nope
the muggles won one of perhaps the most
unknown but very interesting and
extremely dark theories out there came
from reddit reddit Ursula Rita's 365
shared an interesting perspective on the
Wizarding World and said that the
Wizards already had a war with the
muggles and unfortunately the muggles
won the reddit user argues the statement
with several points in the fourth book
we learned that the Minister of Magic
was required to tell the Prime Minister
that he was bringing a dragon into the
country according to the redditor it
seems weird that this rule would exist
in the first place as wizards do a lot
of things in
the muggles without involving the Prime
Minister furthermore the redditor also
argues that there seems to be a strange
lack of powerful wizards
apart from Dumbledore of course could it
be that the ministry strictly regulates
every spell and every wizard and they
ignore quite an advanced muggle
technology that could actually help them
the theory states that near the end of
the middle age the muggle trials were
more successful than the Wizards were
led to believe and that the Ministry of
Magic was created to keep the Wizards in
check after the war the government's
manipulates the Wizards to think that
they're the ones in power when really
they still have to coexist in a much
larger world and that's it for our video
thanks for watching see you next time
[Music]